why's women
need motivation what's it up there with
we're live nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and this channel was designed
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself so get ready
for some success shifting wisdom from
Bob Proctor to give you the motivation
confidence and belief that you need
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one trade your life for worthy goals you
know the law of success is a pretty
interesting concept there's been books
written on it
stories told on it lives have been spent
looking for it let's understand that
everything operates by law the whole
universe operates by law the best
definition of success I have ever heard
was one that Earl Nightingale originated
way back 1959 he said success is the
progressive realisation of a worthy
ideal let's break that down for a moment
success is the progressive continually
moving progressive realization constant
awareness of a worthy ideal and ideal is
an idea that you have fallen in love
with and ideal is an idea that you're
intellectually emotionally and
physically involved with an ideal is an
idea
that you fall in love with success is
the progressive realisation of a worthy
ideal so you don't ask are you worthy of
the idea are you worthy of the good is
it worthy of you now now you're getting
in to love success is it worthy of you
to see what you're gonna do is trade
your life you're trading your life for
whatever it is you're going after so you
want to make up your mind whatever your
goal happens to be whatever you are
pursuing make certain it's worthy of you
because you're chained trading your life
for it the law of success calls for you
to continually move in toward a
predetermined objective
life and bringing your life in harmony
with the laws that govern the entire
universe rule number two manage your
activities think of this for a moment do
you know that every living soul gets
exactly the same amount of time exactly
the same amount of time figure it out
you get all there is a hobo sleeping
under a bridge or on a park bench there
is no material possessions
none does nothing of any constructive
nature that person gets exactly the same
amount of time as the most productive
industrialist in the world we all get
exactly the same amount of time so it's
what we do with the time that makes a
difference I want you to think of the
number of time management programs
almost everyone under the Sun has time
management programs in fact I made one
one time spent a lot of money on it and
then I found out it was a dumb waste of
time and money do you know why time
can't be managed I was having breakfast
with Earl Nightingale one morning and it
was downtown Chicago and I was going
with him on his speaking engagement and
it was early in the morning he said you
want to meet for breakfast whenever I'll
Nigel said you want to meet me I was
there and I always had some
well-prepared questions and I remember I
asked him I said oh how did you learn
how to master time management yeah we're
having breakfast I can still hear his
fork hit the plate he's what the hell
you're talking about he's I've never
mastered time management nobody masters
time management he said time can't be
managed he's I merely manage activity
and he took a little card out of his
pocket and he said every night before I
go to bed I write down six most
important things I have to do tomorrow
these are goal achieving activities and
when I wake up that's when I start
working on and if I don't get them all
done I'll add them to tomorrow's list
you should have about six now if I have
three that I didn't get done today that
doesn't mean I have nine for tomorrow
like six plus these three those three
become part of the six you have to do
the next day when you wake up you give
all your conscious attention to do those
things so you cannot manage time but you
can manage activity you can manage your
activities make certain that what you're
doing really makes a difference make
certain that you're spending your time
on activities that are productive that
are taking you in the direction of your
goal rule number three study yourself I
met a man here in Toronto he was one
that originally got me involved in study
in this race to an furred and he told me
if I didn't like the results I was
getting in my life that I was going to
have to change me because there were my
results and he said if you're gonna
change you you're gonna have to find out
something about yourself and that seemed
to make sense I don't think it was an
earth-shattering idea I wouldn't give
anybody a brain hernia but it made a
hell of a lot of sense to me so I
started to study myself I found most
people don't know who they are they
really don't what do you mean I mean I
know my name I know my age and it's not
you know the average person who they are
they'll give you their name they'll say
I'm Bob Proctor but I'm not Bob and
Proctor two words my parents give them
to me they're called names but it's not
me it's my name then some people say
well this is me but this isn't me either
it's my body like you never flown down
here to the to the studio and say body
won't the end today it's sick okay you
know we don't say em hander em leg it's
my hand my leg my body my name room.i
well that's an interesting question and
I believe if a person was doctors study
that and look for the answer they'll
find it see I think we live
simultaneously on three planes of
understand
for spiritual creatures we have an
intellect and we live in physical bodies
okay because we lack awareness or
understanding of who we are were totally
locked into a physical world and we let
things outside of us control us 95% of
the population are reacting to life
they're not really living at all rule
number four develop your will when
President John Kennedy asked the father
of the space program the famous dr.
Wernher von Braun what it would take to
build a rocket that would carry a person
to the moon and bring him back safely to
earth he answered him in five words the
will to do it the will to do it pretty
light simple answer for such an enormous
question that I'm going to tell you some
of the will to do it it had a lot of
power in it what do we mean by that the
will to do it well will is one of your
higher faculties your perception reason
memory imagination intuition and the
will will is a mental faculty that gives
you the ability to hold one idea on the
screen of the mind to the exclusion of
all outside distractions you know it
would be you'd be hard-pressed to figure
out how many things are trying to grab
your attention at any given time but
there's all kinds of things going on
around that are begging your conscious
attention you can block them all out and
keep one idea on the screen of the mind
with your will will is a mental faculty
that gives you the ability to hold one
idea on the screen of the mind to the
exclusion of all outside distractions
it's the will that gives you the ability
to concentrate concentration is a
powerful mental tool how do you develop
your will I'll tell you you take your
pen or a little black marker and go
opposite to your favorite chair there's
a wall opposite your favorite chair put
a little dot on the wall do it when
nobody sees you doing it and nobody will
ever notice the dots there every time
you sit in that favorite chair focus on
that dot bring all of your conscious
attention to bear on the dot now when
you look at your mind will wonder that's
okay
don't feel bad you're under bring it
back to the dot every time it wanders if
you if you concentrate on the on that
dot for a half a second you'll probably
set a family record our mind is so busy
you focus on the dot you'll find your
mind wander don't feel bad bring it back
to the dot you can get to the point
where you can concentrate for quite a
while and I'm telling you you
concentrate for a while you're
developing great powers or get a candle
in a candle holder and put it somewhere
around your favorite chair when you're
alone light the candle and stare at the
flame and stare at that flame until you
mentally become one with the flame now
again your mind is gonna wander don't
feel bad about it bring it back to the
flame just bring it back to the flame
when you learn to concentrate on one
thing you can concentrate on anything
because that is how you develop your
will also if you want to have more
confidence check at my 254 series it's
free the link to join is in the
description below I was reminded this
morning of a question I'm often asked
how do you eliminate fear from your life
rule number 5 serve up virginity is an
interesting word and like most words
it's misunderstood see the average
person is looking at opportunity is
something they're going to get so
they're all looking to get something
opportunity is what you're going to give
see it's the person that's thinking of
an idea how can I do more how can I
provide more service for the people we
provide service for do you know I spend
almost all of my time thinking of how I
can help you more than I'm helping you
I'm here in my studio we spent a million
dollars building a studio so that I can
communicate more effectively with our
clients opportunity is in giving it's
not receiving it's not getting it's
giving it's sharing it's putting
something out there rule number six get
real success success is a funny word
nightingale had a great definition for
it he said a person successful if they
know where they are and they know where
they're going and they're progressively
moving in that
direction he said that success was the
progressive realisation of a worthy
ideal anyone that has a goal and they're
moving towards it they're successful
most people think that you're successful
if you have a lot of money quite often
you have a lot of money if you're
successful but it isn't I wouldn't say
mother Teresa has a lot of money okay
but she's a pretty successful lady rule
number seven use your imagination
attracting what you actually want I
think James Allen put it very well in
his little book as a man thinketh he
said you don't attract what you want you
attract what you are now think about
that if you want to attract what you
want you've got to see yourself already
with it you've got to understand that
you've already got it first of all
clearly understand this nothing is
created or destroyed that means
everything's already here if not in one
state certainly in another where did the
iPhone come from the iPhone came from a
series of ideas that individuals
entertained in their mind and they kept
holding the idea until the stuff came to
them that enabled them to build the
phone the stuff had already been here
nothing is created or destroyed all
science all theology deep sigh if
nothing is created or destroyed
everything that is already here our
problem is we've got to wait until we
see it outside before we believe we've
got it start dealing with the
non-physical world with the invisible
world with the world that you can't see
through these little peepers that you've
got here we call eyes start to see
yourself mentally you've been given the
faculties to do that use your
imagination see yourself already in
possession of the good you desire that
will flip your mind on to a specific
frequency and you do think on
frequencies it's on that frequency that
good you desire is going to start coming
towards you and you will start moving
toward it if you want to attract what
you actually want
you've got to see yourself now already
with it and no it's only a period of
time until you moving toward it and then
moving toward you and you become one
with it rule number eight shift your
paradigm stop and think of any large
company I don't care
anyone right
you can go to the leaders of that
company and you can say who are your
stars I mean the ones that are really
making it happen and they've all got a
few say what are they doing that's so
different why don't you find out what
they're doing they teach it everybody
they all well everybody couldn't do it
why are they doing it you know something
the stars don't know why they're stars
and they'll say well they're smart some
of them aren't very smart smarts got
nothing to do with it they have shifted
their paradigm they've knocked the wall
down and they built an image and they
followed the rules they just didn't know
what they were doing I didn't know what
I was doing I was there know for a
million dollars here I had no idea what
the hell I was doing I'd say I was
cleaning offices that was almost
incidental what I was doing
I was reading this every day I was
listening to the recordings every day I
was reprogramming my subconscious mind
rule number nine control your happiness
everybody wants to be happy but not
everybody is happy you know I could take
you back to the man that gave me this
book Rey Stanford I was a very unhappy
individual I was a sad soul believe me
and I remember one day he said Proctor
you're gonna have to change would you
like to be happy well I used to think
that was something that happened to some
people but you weren't in control of it
I really never knew that I could control
my own happiness I did not know that and
I'm gonna tell you something there's a
whole lot of people do not know that
otherwise you wouldn't find so many
people who are pretty sad he's I'm gonna
tell you a secret Proctor and he said if
you get it you can benefit from this
till you're a very
man he said you are in control of your
own happiness and I said I'm going to
tell you why you're not happy there's a
power or a thought energy flowing into
your consciousness and you know what you
do you bottle it all up inside all of
your energies focused on you you are
only thing you think about poor me I
wish that some money I wished I wish to
wish to wish but your thought you're
always about yourself if you find
someone else to help if you can help
someone and I'm gonna tell you there's a
whole lot of people out there want help
if you will focus on helping other
people you're gonna be one happy cat no
I don't think I got it right away but he
knew probably I wasn't gonna get it
right away and so every time I some he's
really been helping my man and I don't
know I wasn't helping anybody I was
trying to figure out how to get some
money how to help me I want you to think
about this for a moment there's so many
people need help
chapter 14 and the science of getting
rich is a powerful concept leave
everyone with the impression of increase
if you do that you're helping people
happiness is always found and the person
who is focusing on helping other people
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is get unstuck
what keeps people stuck month after
month year after year that ninety seven
percent of the population er stop
you've got people graduating with all
kinds of degrees and the results would
indicate that they know very much at all
most people don't understand what's
going on inside there's something that's
stopping them is called a paradigm see
when paradigms are in control nothing
changes nothing and that's why most
people they have the same results year
after year people know how to do better
than they're doing the problem is they
don't know why they're not doing what
they know how to do see it's the
paradigm that produces the result and if
we're going to change the result there's
only one way to do it just one you can
change the paradigm
a man's environment is a merciless year
of him as a human being and the penises
my amethyst and love improvement all he
has to do is improve on this environment
will improved reflect the changing man
all knowledge all power is a hundred
percent evenly president all place at
the same time your spiritual DNA is
perfect so is mine
there's perfection within you gotta
learn just draw it out no I've got a
special bond escaped from Bob on how to
create healthy relationships that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
is time for the three-point landing
questions time to go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one where do you need to
get unstuck number two what does real
success look like for you and number
three how can you better serve someone
today you know I think what everybody
wants is healthy relationships what do
we mean by that well healthy in a good
state in a very good state and that's
the way we want the relationship how do
you create a healthy relationship I'll
tell you how you start take your mind
off yourself put it on the other person
if you really want to have a healthy
relationship with people follow wallace
wattles advice in chapter 14 of the
science of getting rich leave every
person you meet with the impression of
increase leave every person with the
impression of increase have them better
off because they've met you if you want
to create healthy relationships put all
your focus on the person you want the
healthy relationship with give them the
best you've got fall in love with the
idea of helping the other person enjoy
an abundant life which is their
birthright that is how you're going to
create a healthy relationship and that's
the way all of your relationships should
be
if you want 10 more awesome rules from
Bob check out their video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there when you get a real good idea you
should act on it
if you hold yourself back because of
fear your life actually comes to a stop